hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent attacking game to share with
you from 1900
on the white end the Great Harry Nelson
Pillsbury
and he's playing against Georg Marco
this is a model game for the Pillsbury
attack and who better to show us the way
than the pioneer of this very attack
on board
we have a very popular position out of
the Queen's Gambit declined
play continues with B6 not quite the
tartik hour variation
the tartar Tower is
after first including H6 Bishop H4
blacks claiming
H6 is more useful than Bishop H4 nice to
have the flight Square in most cases
all right in this game it's B6 straight
away of course totally playable
play continues with Bishop to D3
pointing at the king side
and Bishop to B7 so it's after the
bishop has abandoned this diagonal that
white releases the tension
C takes d
e takes D black could of course consider
taking with a piece instead and try to
control the center with pieces but
a pawn is now going to be around to try
and restrict White Center
now the bishop is blocked by the pawn
but do know that it is still functioning
it has indirect support
over a night jump into E4
now there are a couple prerequisites for
the Pillsbury attack so if you're
trying to implement this in one of your
own games here are the things to look
for one
Black's Queen Bishop needs to be fiend
kettled in two it needs to be obstructed
by a pawn
we'll see why this is the case
in just a little bit
now White's next move is what signals
the Pillsbury attack Knight E5 this is
the first piece Improvement in the
position
and it is time sensitive
it's important not to play this position
on autopilot it's the opening I'm
supposed to Castle no castling now
will allow black to get here first
controlling E5
and now if you hop in you're knocked out
right away
and you have to take with the d-pawn
which means this Pawn has the chance to
move
totally different structures are now on
board four to two for black on the queen
side five versus three for white on the
king side different structure different
game
95 now
Knight D7 f for totally different story
if the Knight is captured in this case
white will gladly take towards the
center
and the King Rook will be especially
excited about the half open def file
now
with this last move it is not without
its drawbacks there's now a gap created
on e4
and
for the next few moves by black this is
an appealing continuation to hop
straight in to E4 and I'd like to touch
on this variation
first of all
what is the night jump doing it's
creating tension between the Bishops
it's helping black to develop on E7 and
it's interfering with the Bishops when
we consider the light Square Bishops
for each side
they're not opposing each other they're
you know pointing in totally different
directions but there is that one
intersection Square E4
there is a way to interfere with this
guy pointing right at the king Side by
hopping into the hole by hopping into E4
so let's have a look at this variation
you could see how black could consider
continuing
Queen Knight Could Fall In The King
Knight's footsteps this is a nice way
forward for black the idea in a way is
to work around this strongly placed
Knight on E5
maybe one day black could even consider
uh some some continuation like this
where
once there isn't tonight on F6 you could
think about F6
now remember that earlier point I
pointed out with uh H6
it might be a more difficult piece to
kick away if H6 is already in there
you'd have a new Square to worry about
is black there'd be a hole created on G6
if you have the opportunity to play the
Pillsbury attack I think what you may
find
is that the inclusion of H6 makes the
attack
a little more appealing might be more
difficult for black to try and extract
the knight from E5
okay
in any event after F4 E4 as a whole
black could think about hopping straight
in right now
even a couple of moves later
play continues in this game with C5
and white now castles this is another
opportunity for black to make use of the
E4 Square
with first a capture and then hopping in
with a similar continuation as I just
shared
now one of the thoughts that I had in
preparing for this video in preparing
with this game
is
you know I kept seeing that Eve Knight
to E4 was a really nice move for black
so I thought to myself
wait a second remember how
we didn't Castle in that one position we
went with Knight to E5 could we maybe do
without castling in this position and
instead play Queen to F3 another move
that is characteristic of the Pillsbury
attack another move that characterizes
the Pillsbury attack is this queen F3
move
um this is not a good move to play while
uncastled and there is a beautiful
variation I just have to highlight those
of you who enjoy geometry are maybe
going to fall in love with this one
um it's important to first be castled
before playing Queen F3 and here's why
check this line out
C takes d e takes D now the Knight jumps
in
the Bishops are in tension they're
exchanged
Knight takes Knight Pawn takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight black is winning
this position
after Knight takes Knight
this is awesome for black of course
if you take the Knight with the d-pawn
the queen gets to go to B4 with check
and the bishop is hit for a second time
black wins a piece and if you take in
the other direction with the F Pawn the
queen makes use of H4 with check and
still wins that Bishop
that is a really neat line that
highlights the importance of first
castling
that Queen on E7 opposite the King has
these two excellent pivots on B4 and H4
okay
castles first in this case
play continues with now c4 this is where
black starts to
go in the wrong direction
it is better to take and then hop into
E4 but That Never Comes
in this game it's C4 this releases the
pressure on D4 Bishop backs off stays
off the back rank
stays pointing towards the king side
and now in comes A6 so why
was black playing C for
was the train of thought oh I'm
attacking the bishop and if he doesn't
see it I'm gonna win the bishop
definitely not
the idea here is to with C4 create a
majority on the queen side with this
last move black has created a three to
two majority on the queen side and in
time
black can produce a past Pawn
but doesn't have the time for that
because this attack is coming really
fast at the black king position
A6 preparing B5 B4 but now in comes
Queen F3 only after castles
you'll notice in this position
if black tries to hop into E4 black
would end up losing a pawn now
after takes takes takes Knights move
backwards the C Pawn is lost
okay so black simply continues running
with the majority A6
Queen F3 now there's no hopping in here
we have too much Support over it in
comes B5
and now Queen H3
it's this Knight on E5 and Queen on H3
that really characterize the Pillsbury
attack
and with this last move by white
the planets are really aligning notice
the pressure on D7 by the king Knight
and the pressure on H7 by the king
bishop and look how the queen
coordinates with them both
intersection squares deep in Black's
camp
that's where accidents happen
tactics for white in other words they
are right around the corner
in the game black continues with G6
if black continued
storming away
on the king side with B4
this one is over because of these
tactics you ready
Knight takes Knight would follow
if you're taking the Knight it's going
to be a mate and two check check May
and if you take with the Knight it's
mate straight away
and what else if you take with the queen
there's this trick Bishop takes H7
Knight takes Bishop Queen takes Queen we
win the queen king in the corner we're
still going to win the queen discover
check she's a goner
okay no time for B4
black tries to shut down this diagonal
and does
temporarily
at the same time
black has provided white a hook
with F5
so now
in time both white Rooks will soon flood
the king position because of this
engagement
upon exchange will occur the file will
be peeled open there is no save here for
black this is overwhelming
from here it's B4
F takes G6 no time to take the Knight
because we're smashing through on F6
we're eliminating The Defenders of H7
so what is tried is the immediate
recapture
and now in comes Queen H4 this is
excellent pressure on the Knight that is
now pinned no great way to unpin it
no no way to make use of these squares
and still try and defend the bishop
don't have access to those squares
in the game it is
Han takes Knight if you're trying a move
like King 2 G7 you simply get rocked
back
and white is smashing through
with Bishop takes G6 or excuse me Knight
takes G6 threatening mate
Pawn takes Knight we have check
we could smash through here we just take
stuff everything is super forceful
there's a check there's a checkmate
King to G7
doesn't work it's going to lead to mate
what is tried is B takes Knight
now in comes Knight takes Knight
Queen takes Knight and we're taking on
F6 with the Rook white would prefer to
end up with the bishop on F6
uh carving into the dark squares looking
for maid on h8
at the same time F1 is now vacant for
that final attacking piece
the queen Rook
black attempts to try and save this one
with A5 Queen Rook trying to fight over
that F6 Square too late
the Rooks are doubled
Rook A6
Bishop takes G6
threatening made on H7 how do you stop
it
can't stop it it's a forced mate
Rook takes Rook check
Rook takes Bishop check Queen h8 check
King F7 is the only move
Queen H7 check there are three options
now for the king
E6 E8 f8
if you go to these two the White Queen
mimics the king's movement
and it's mate on the spot
King E6 King G6
King E8 Queen G8
the move played in this game
King f8
allowing Queen takes Queen
and black resigns there is no continuing
here it is a maiden 2.
with these very moves no matter what
black does
Bishop H6
Queen G7 game over
this is a beautiful attacking game by
Pillsbury
26 mover
uh a fantastic finish great to see that
nice build up on the king side
let's have a look at the tail the tape
on this one we could see just how
accurate Pillsbury was playing
in 1900
the one blunder
that is being registered we cannot
consider a blunder Rook a to F1 uh going
from a maintenance 11
to just a plus seven we can hardly
consider that a blunder 96 accuracy
versus 83 very high quality game and
maybe one that you may want to consider
experimenting with in some of your own
games if you have the opportunity to do
so so
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye